hello everyone
thank you for watching the talk
in this talk i'm going to be talking
about explicit abelian lifts and quantum
ldpc codes the joint work with fernando
ryan pedro and mother
so the main goal of the work is to
explicitly build symmetric expanding
graphs
uh so in the talk i'll try to motivate
as to why this problem is worthy of
study
and uh
how we construct such graphs this
beautiful image uh from the survey by
huri linear and wiki design is of the
three regular infinite tree
whose questions give us
expanded graphs
all right
so
the outline of the talk is as follows
we'll introduce the problem and give
some history of it
and then we'll state our results
and show how they can be achieved to use
quantum ltpc codes
i will not really talk about the proof
or the proof sketch
but i would like to single out the key
or technical lemma that goes into the
proof which is
a better account of a certain
combinatorial object
and will then conclude with
the summary and open problems
okay so let's get started
so expansion is one of the key uh graph
uh properties that has been very useful
uh in certain computer science
and it's a notion that captures how well
connected a graph is
right
uh formally there are multiple notions
of uh
uh what this thing is and we're going to
look at the spectral definition
so
let a g be the adjacency matrix of the
car
uh you can compute its eigenvalue and
here lambda 2 is the second largest
eigen value lambda n is the smallest
cycle
right so define this quantity called
lambda g of graph t
and
the smaller the value is the better you
expand
right
so for example the complete graph which
is the best an expander can get has
lambda of k n is one
and
the main task is can we have partial
graphs
right like ideally constant degree
graphs that achieve this
so if you graph a g regular
and in the worst case is disconnected uh
then you lambda g is d so this is like
the worst possible
it can be and the question is how uh
how much
smaller than d can you make this uh
quantity
now this uh
captures the notion of random walks and
how quickly a random box makes so this
image illustrates
a simulation of a random walk and in a
well connected dense well connected
graph random walk should mix pretty
quickly
right
so
given d and epsilon
can you construct infinite families of d
regular graphs
g n so here we want to think of n as the
number of vertices of the graph
which goes to infinity so you want an
ever
increasing
family of graphs
such that the spectrum the this eigen
value
is bounded
right
so the second largest eigen value is
bounded away
uh
by from d by its absolutely right and
here the key thing is you have the
freedom to choose
uh to construct this graphs once you
give your next epsilon right so you can
make them very small
uh
the best you can do
uh given by this bound by alan boppin
now it says that uh
ignoring uh vanishing factors with n
asymptotically the best you can do is
two square of d minus one
and graphs that achieve that are called
romantic graphs and they are like the
optimum expansions
uh whereas when we say epsilon d we are
asking for a much more
modest
uh requirement
right uh however
for applications epsilon d more than
suffices
so
this is a good enough problem to attack
all right the other uh very interesting
property the grasshopper is symmetry
right so formally
a graph isomorphism or an automorphism
is a biceptive map between the vertices
such that
every endpoint of an edge
are mapped to endpoints of another edge
right
so if you have u and v are adjacent then
f of u and f of p are edges
and vice versa
okay so such maps are called
isomorphisms or
and if you collect the set of all the
types of morphisms they form a group
under the action of under the group
operation of composition right composing
two bijective analysis your bijective
map and moreover the property satisfied
so
this is the group of automorphisms
and the question is given a group
h
can you construct a graph
such that h is a subgroup of this
automobile right can you construct a
graph t
with this property uh
so let's take a simple example let's say
the group is a cyclic group
right
then there's a very natural
graph that you can build
so let's say this is the cycle graph on
six elements
and this has
uh
z6 as as the subgroup of its
automorphism group because for every i
in or 6c uh so it's think of is from
zero to five
you can define an isomorphism
that shifts the elements by i
right that rotates the circle by i
and this gives you an iphone
all right
so
so we've seen two properties so
expansion
the question that i asked has been
solved and by now
we know a lot of explicit constructions
of constant degree expanders
right
on the other hand if you just ask for
symmetry
we also know how to do this
so
baba in the 70s showed that for any
finite group h you can explicitly
construct this class
whose automorph is grown is exactly h
not just contained
right
and
the existential result was known all the
way back in 30s
okay so now
what remains
is
to ask if you can get both right
why not get two nice things
and this is the focus of it
so why would you want to do it there are
multiple reasons
let's look at two of them
the one that motivated us to get this uh
is the recent uh
slew of results on constructions of
quantum and dpc codes
so given to linear codes c1 and c2 which
have a symmetry of a certain group h you
can define a quantum css code out of it
by taking the tensorflow product and
doing some sort of a quotient operation
on it
that you won't get into
but the key thing is
you need a symmetry of the group
and this was defined
originally by hastings high and odon
and also shortly after also used by
pandelive and color chef in the case
when h is a cyclic group so using this
they gave newer quantum codes uh that
had a much better distance than
predecessors
and the work of cantaloupe collective in
fact gives almost linear distance
goods
moreover the recent breakthrough results
of the universe name robot k moses on
classical
locally testable codes of constant
distance and rate
and the work of panel even color chip
that uh gave both classical locally
testable codes as well as good quantum
dpc ports of linear distance ending rate
was can be seen as a
construction of similar construction
where the group is no longer a billion
ah but it's this matrix root psl to f
cube
of two by two matrices with determinant
one
model of the scalars
all right so in this work it is crucial
that
the code is symmetric and this code is
uh in fact obtained by
the tanner port so it's like by the
construction of ships and spillman
so you need an expanding car
so you need an expanding graph with the
symmetry of a group which translates to
the symmetry of the code and the
expansion translates to
uh the nice distance properties
right
another application that i found really
interesting uh was the recent paper by
goldrich and victorsin which builds the
expander graph says that the
automorphism group is trivial
and then they use it to
show certain lower bounds in property
testing
so the key takeaway here is that uh
it's uh nice to have expansion but it's
uh even better to have a control over
its symmetrics right
and
our formal uh problem statement
therefore is that given a family of
groups h n
can we explicitly construct a family of
expanded graphs g a
so that h n is a subgroup of its
automotive
right um here the notion of explicitness
that we work with is polynomial time
in the size of the graph so we're good
with deterministic polynomial time
algorithms
in the size of the graph g there are
stronger notions of explicitness and
we do not
work with them for the purposes of the
talk
right and notice here that we've relaxed
the condition
of h not being exactly equal but just a
subgroup because this suffices for the
application
to quantify
okay
so what are known techniques
so the raman is in the most optimum
ramanjian
graph or first construction using
algebraic techniques
uh that
can be seen as scaling graphs over
certain groups like psl fq
and
these are indeed very symmetric graphs
however uh
this is not a generic technique so you
could not
apply it for any group because the set
of generators is constructed in a very
specific
way using number theory
so
although these give great uh expanders
with the optimum bound
uh they we just know them for a
specific set of groups right
all right
so the most generic technique you could
think of uh is
via kelly graph so
if you want symmetries of edge you you
might want to consider kd graphs over h
over some some generating set and what
alan and right show is that if you do
not want to remember theory
then just take a random set
right so just pick a random subset of
size log n
where n is the size of your group
and you will get an expanded graph with
high probability
the issue of course
is that we aren't happy with login uh we
want constantly graphs uh so this would
mean that the degree is logarithmic and
that wouldn't work for example in the
coding theory application because
the degree corresponds to the sparsity
of the
matrix and for ldpc or trolling
constitutions
right
and uh moreover this boundary style uh
when the group is abelian right so
of course when the group is non-availing
you have constituted graphs but uh when
the group is a billion like for example
the cyclic group uh that was used uh
like i mentioned in the earlier work on
quantum codes
uh you cannot beat this right
so
so this method isn't good enough for us
uh so we use the next uh
very useful technique of lifting which
is again a very generic technique uh
introduced in the context of graphs and
construction of expanders by below and
linear
and you can look at it as a special case
of a very generic
logical topological notion of covering
maps
if you view the graph as a topological
object
right and this has been used a lot to
construct expanders
so let's see what this operation is
so we define this
a notion of lift called the hl effect up
where you start the base graph
and you want to lift it to a large
algorithm
called g of s
and here l controls the
the amount of
lift you want to do so for every vertex
you replace it with l copies so you have
q1 all the way up to ul
similarly you have it for v
and now for each edge
in your base graph uv
you you replace it with a perfect magic
and this matching or this permutation is
given by the signing function s
so
therefore i denote the lifted graph as a
function of this s
so
this signing function maps an edge to a
permutation
and uh so we want to think of this as a
subgroup of the permutation so when i
say an edge i lift
my permutations to be the sub
and then
i just map i to s of e times i where the
permutation adds something
right
so
now this is a fun example you can try
out you can just pause the video here so
can you look at this cycle graph
at the left of this monograph
uh
and the answer is yes you can uh so if
you take a graph on three uh elements
and now let's say i'm just doing a two
lift
right
so so the symmetry group of on two
elements
has just
either the triple permutation or the
flip
so on the edge one two and two three i
have the trivial permutation whereas on
the
on the third edge i have a flip
and i have two copies of each vertex and
in this one place i have flipped
the matching and in the other two i just
have the trigger
so now it's easy to see
that this on
the cycle
graph
all right
so let's see why this lifting is a nice
operation
so
the first thing is that we can very
explicitly characterize the spectrum of
the liquid graph g of s
in terms of the signing s and this is
very useful because at the end of the
day we need to bound the eigenvalues of
the graph
moreover it preserves degree and
therefore you can build a tower or a
sequence of lifts and
which is why it is an often used tools
and constructions of expanders you can
keep you can start with the base graph
and build repeated depth
moreover if h is a billion
then h acts on this so h is a subgroup
of the symmetric group of the automotive
group
of g of s and h acts in the natural way
where it permutes the l copies of a
certain vertex
right so for each vertex you have l
copies and h acts as a permeation of
those
and this is very useful for us because
we want to construct such graphs
and
roughly speaking uh we'll get into the
details of this
if your base graph is good enough
and if you put the signing
uniformly at random
so for example in the two lift case in
the example we saw earlier
if i just pick the
s of an edge to be plus or minus one
with
equal probability
then the lifted graph is known to be an
expander with high probability
right and the challenge here is to do
randomizing
or in other words to construct a finding
in a deterministic fashion
all right
so
let's look at a quick history of lifting
so like i mentioned it was uh
introduced by video and menial
uh and they derandomized the two limbs
so they they showed an existential
result
and they derandomized it uh for two
lifts
uh
using techniques uh discrepancy based
techniques uh they essentially gave a
converse of this
lemma and that allowed them to obtain a
bound of square root d
up to polylog uh factors
now this was uh extended recently by
aggravating
kola in madan or to cliffs
for l
going all the way to two to the
n
roughly
and uh
they also improve the spectral graph uh
the spectral guarantee however it's an
existential result it's not an
length construction
uh on the other hand marcus piedmont
stevenson came up with the
breakthrough work which introduced the
technique of interlacing polynomials
and they gave
they exhibited the existence of two lift
which preserves the ramanujan power
right so there's no loss here so you get
the optimum expanders another set of
work by mohanty o'donnell and paradise
uh
uses the trace part method
and they also obtain two lifts and they
use it to construct
graphs expanding graphs for every degree
using this technique and they obtain an
almost domination power so for every
epsilon
uh you can get an expanding family
with eigenvalue bounded by two square
would be minus one plus
right
okay so
what do we
aim to achieve here
so
as you have seen
right a lot of the works work with two
left
whereas the existential result of accm
shows that
there are good signings even when you
take l as 2 to the n over dq
right
and they show that and they also give a
negative result it says that
beyond 2 to the nd
you cannot hope for any expansion if
your group is a billion
so now our task is to
construct such a billion diff when l is
in the range from 3
to
this this upper bound of
2 to the nt
right
so in particular
can we construct it for the cyclic group
because this would be randomized the
result of pk as i had diluted to earlier
right
and
that's more or less what we do
so for any d
a large enough n and a nicely growing
function l okay
we have an explicit family of directly
expanding graphs
such that
each graph gn is a zero lift of some
brace graph
and note here that
we can generalize uh this result from zl
to any transitive ability group
transitivity is necessary because
otherwise the group would be
disconnected the graph would be
disconnected and you cannot hope for
expansion
so this essentially covers all a billion
groups
and the niceness of the function
is the function should lie in this green
region
so starting from 2
we can lift all the way to 2 to the n to
the
c where c is some fixed constant
and we can also lift when l is
exactly exponential so it's 2 to the c n
for any c
right
note that
we
actually achieve all the way to the
bound
by ackn
while their existential result hold for
a slightly smaller image
so
this is the key result
and this explicit again in the sense
that we can output the graph in
polynomial time
and to
put this back into perspective
uh we look at our result as like a union
of two results
so in the exponential reading when your
l is uh actually some fixed uh
exponential in n
then we can think of this as a
generalization of the work of bino
linear and in fact we use their key
lemma the converse of expander mixing
number
which gives us and bound very similar to
this
and on the other hand you can also look
at it as a re-randomization of the
result of ac km
so what we do is we give a
simpler proof of their results
with a slightly weaker parameters
using the lemma from below linear and
mediaranium
on the other hand
in the other regime the
slightly smaller lift regime
uh
that can be thought of as a
generalization of the work of mop
because here we
use similar
uh strategy like we use the tracebar
method
and we are able to uh
get the almost harmonizing bounds
for
l that is as large as 2 to the n to the
f where f is some function of epsilon
right
whereas if you want to lift all the way
to a fixed constant to an absolute
constant then we lose
in parameters and get a bound of epsilon
d
but which is good enough still good
enough to get expanders
all right
and
uh let's recall that in the work of
panther leave and colleges that i
alluded to earlier
uh given a d regular expanding graph on
nl vertices
if the graph is a lift of a graph
or in general if it's
it has this
symmetry of zl
then you can construct a good quality
cyclic code
linear code with circular in size n
and a quantum code with the parameters
uh
with these parameters where nl is the
block length and has a rate and l is the
distance
this is why we want l to be as large as
possible as a function of n
because that controls how
good the code is in terms of the
distance
right
so as a corollary we have explicit
polynomial time constructions of good
quasi-cyclic ldpc codes so
cyclic codes are like an approximation
of the cyclic codes where uh
you allow
more than one orbits of the cycle right
so here you have roughly log n orbits
and these are good quality codes
on the other hand we do not know about
the existence of uh good
cyclic codes so
this is in itself a very interesting
result
we also get quantum ldpc codes with uh
almost linear distance
uh and these are explicit uh
i mean uh the work of pandelif college
have also gives these codes but that's a
randomized construction where each
signing is very again constructive graph
but you do it randomly so the sign of
each graph is uniformly at right
and using their balancing trick
we can get uh le pc codes
with distance n to the 1 minus alpha so
for any alpha between 0 and 1
you get distance n to the 1 minus alpha
and dimension into the f
so now
i would like to briefly mention the key
uh technical
contribution
but i will not go into the details
is that of a better count of
a certain object called hikes
so the tracebar method
is a fairly common method
and a variation of this was used
initially by friedman in his
groundbreaking result
uh which was uh
simplified by both the knob recently and
used by mop
so let's quickly define hikes as
singleton free uh
non-biocrafting box
i'm going to explain this shortly
and
what the method essentially
gives you is a reduction from computing
a spectral count quantity or bounding a
spectral quantity
in terms of counting certain objects
right so it says that the maximum
spectral maximum eigenvalue of this
adjacency matrix
can be bounded by
counting heights
of length 2k
over this graph
here b stands for the
non-backtracking work matrix but we
won't get into the details of that so
let's see what a hike is right so a hike
is a singleton free non-backtracking
block
so at each step you cannot backtrack the
edge you have come from
and moreover
no edges traverse exactly once
so either it's traversed at least twice
or it's never traversed
so for example on this graph
the sequence of steps so you start from
this vertex and then you have the
following sequence of steps
and
you can verify that this is
indeed a closed walk
where each edge
is
either traversed twice
or there's this edge which is never
trapped so it's a singleton free
non-backtracking book
and the goal is to count all such works
on a certain base graph
now
if you cross a d regular then there's a
trivial way to count it which is uh d
minus 1 to the 2k because at each step
you have d minus 1 options
so except for the first step but every
other step you cannot backtrack so you
have d minus 1 potential neighbors
so you get this count and
once you plug this in here you notice
that you get an eigen value bound of
order of d
right which is trivial because we've
seen that lambda g is at most d
on the other hand
an ideal count would be of b minus 1 to
the k
because
uh that would give you a closer
ramanujan bomb it will give you 2 square
root -1
so now the goal is uh
to get an efficient
count as close to d minus 1 to the k as
possible
and
note that here i
this method works
for any k
however for
multiple reasons
there are certain constraints so
and the key controlling parameter is the
size n right so how much of the lift you
want
dictates more or less how long you need
to work
right or how long of a walk you need to
uh compute the heights for
so
in mops work
they focus on tool
so it suffices to
bound box of length login
and for for such length box they give a
optimal
count
whereas we would like to lift much
larger than our two lifts
so
we extend the bound
to
end to the
delta where delta is a function of
epsilon and e
and uh if you're okay with the weaker
bound
uh we can get it all the way to a fixed
polynomial in a
right these are much longer box
and
we do this by
counting
in a very different manner
so
so let's define the high graph to be a
sub graph of the graph
of the base graph which is traversed by
the height right so this is the sub
graph that you see on your walk
and we're going to count heights by
dividing it into two steps
so first we count all possible height
graphs
and then for each high graph we can
count the number of heights that can
correspond to such a graph
uh the second step is uh
comparatively easier
for the first
we count all high graphs by encoding a
dfs traverses because once you have a
dfs traversal you can
compute the graph
uniquely
and there are two encodings
that we give so a simpler one is
resistor at each step whether you it's a
backtracking step or a record system
so for a backtracking step you do not
need any more data uh whereas for
recursive step you need which of the
which of your d neighbors you would like
to recurse
or rather d minus one since it's not
backtracking
right
whereas
when k is
not too large so it is n to the
delta first this function of epsilon
you have that the high graph is parts
right and each vertex so there's a lot
of vertex with degree exactly two
so for these vertices
you have to uh
records you cannot backtrack on such
vertices and using this observation uh
you can compress the above encoding
further
so using this kind of a compression uh
let's us recover the almost ramanujan
bomb
right
and then you can count the number of
hikes corresponding to a given graph
so yeah this is a very intuition of what
uh the ingredient of the key
counting lemma is
and of course there are a bunch of
pseudo randomness tools
and others that we use but
those are relatively more standard
so let's conclude
so the summary
is that we give explicit constructions
of lifted graphs
of h comma l lifted graphs
for
every ability in group h
transitive billing group h and
a large range of lift sizes l
the key method of analysis is the trace
power method
and to do so it utilizes a very careful
count of the special box called heights
on a suitably nice
base graph
which has
a lot of nice properties
including large good
or rather a large bicycle free radius
and as an application we can use such
graphs to get uh new explicit ldbc forms
uh
so this is the randomized system there
is a panel of color chair and we get
classical quasi-cyclic ldpc codes
and quantum ldpc codes
uh and this work uh opens a lot of open
problems
so you could uh
first thing would be to extend this
almost no management all the way to two
to the n
right so we have this almost
only uh for a certain regime and pretty
nice to push it all the way
or even like the first step would be to
get expanders in the red regime for
which we don't have
any guarantees yet
moreover
we use a bunch of uh different
encodings and different techniques uh in
this in these three different regimes
and it would be nice to have a uniform
proof
a very unified
way to do these
to do the analysis
uh and the notion of strongly explicit
time
right so
as i mentioned our notion of
explicitness isn't the strongest one
because we take polynomial time the size
of the graph
uh whereas there are stronger notions so
is this uh
can we make this strongly exist
because there are some applications
there that uh which is really useful
right
and then it would be nice to generalize
this
to some families of non-abilities
so for example the breakthrough work i
mentioned initially used an honorable
input psl to fq
but it managed to do that using uh the
already existing graphs of
robots phillips and sarnak
and some variants of those
so
it would be very nice to have these for
newer families uh especially the family
is not covered by the work of all 207
and to see if they can lead to
nice applications even possibly outside
of coding theory
right uh so thank you so much for
listening to the talk
uh
uh it'll be very nice to have feedback
and i'll be very happy to answer
questions uh please write to me
at my email
also fernando has given a
very nice talk at iis which is much
longer so it covers the basics and goes
into a lot of context
so
please check it out on youtube if you
have the time and i'm interested
thank you so much